merci monsieur le président madame la
première ministre sioniste de
l'intérieur mes chers collègues notre
maison brûle sous nos yeux vingt mille
600 hectares de brûler 36000 personnes
évacuées la crise climatique en gironde
provoque un drame humain économique
environnemental depuis huit jours deux
feux qualifiés de hors norme à la teste
de buch à landiras ravage notre
département et avancent vers le massif
landais j'aimerais rendre hommage aux
membres des 10 de la drc i ainsi qu'à
tous les invisibles de cette crise qui
lutte quotidiennement sur le terrain pas
de victime à déplorer dans ce contexte
c'est remarquable je voudrais également
remercier le président du sénat pour sa
visité le temps nécessaire qu'il a
consacré à écouter l'ensemble des
acteurs et plus particulièrement les
élus locaux
dans ces moments là des visites éclair
ministériels sont particulièrement
contre productive la gironde constitue
le plus grand massif résineux en europe
et pourtant notre département ne dispose
d'aucun canadair à demeure en provenance
de nîmes et ils sont arrivés plus de 12
heures après le début de l'incendié
autrefois il était à mérignac nous le
savons tous chaque minute de gagner est
primordial
propriété de l'état leur maintenance a
été délégué un prestataire privé
seulement quatre avions dash sur 6 9
canadairs sur douze sont en mesure de
voler les deux tiers ont plus de 25 ans
nous luttons contre la crise climatique
avec des moyens du siècle passé monsieur
le ministre comptez vous renforcer la
flotte européenne et nationale
relocalisé au moins deux canadairs dans
le sud ouest
comptez vous contribuez à la création
d'un secrétariat d'état au risque civile
et crise majeure
vous répondre
[Musique]